do you know who's the greatest
third-party candidate of all time
probably ross ferrara ross pro you know
tom who would you put as the greatest
republican candidate i'm sorry the the
third party candidate of all time in
terms of effectiveness and polling and
acceptance i think in my lifetime it's
been ross pro
you know you know who it is if you think
about it it's abraham lincoln abraham
lincoln amen
i said the exact same thing though i i
just discovered it relatively he's the
first republican there was no republican
abraham lincoln is the greatest third
party there was like democrats and wigs
right yeah the republican party was the
brand new startup party when lincoln
wins in 1860 with 39.8 percent of the
vote
you know
there were four candidates right and now
you don't think about it because you're
like oh republicans it's one of the two
major parties but they were brand new in
1860 and here's another wrinkle when he
runs for a re-election in 1864 his vice
presidential
uh candidate is from the other party he
ran a unity ticket where he's the
republican and why hasn't nobody done
that since then i feel like there's a a
a yearning for something like that i
feel like if a republican and a democrat
work together and show that they can get
along the country would be like dude
that's amazing i love it well who did
that tom who who is it that lieberman
who is it that did john john mccain
tiptoed around having joe lieberman and
the democrat join him right and then he
ended up choosing sarah palin yeah and i
talked to someone about that decision
who actually got a call from john mccain
to the time being like hey what do you
think if i uh choose joe lieberman uh
and the the political calculation was
not there for him it's like he thought
that
sarah palin was going to help more
politically but it was a real missed
opportunity if you enjoyed the short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]